délibéré est conscient de lancer la
guerre quand nous pouvions encore
négocier la paix déclarations du chef de
l'état français emmanuel macron qui
s'est entretenu avec le président russe
vladimir poutine il lui a demandé de
mettre fin aux combats mais il laisse
ouvert le chemin du dialogue avec moscou
armelle charrier merci d'être avec nous
est ce que les sanctions prises contre
la russie vont avoir des ailes vont
avoir des conséquences pour les
européens on le disait tout à l'heure
est ce que les populations européennes
elles elles sont prêtes à en payer le
prix non je ne pense pas mais pour
l'instant elle nous paraît réaliser
parce que payer le prix concret pour les
ukrainiens c'est si vous êtes dans une
guerre vous avez une action guerre et
donc à un moment donné on va vous
demander un effort donc là peut-être que
vous pouvez être conscient de ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté et vous pouvez
dans ces cas-là partager la souffrance
partagée la difficulté le problème c'est
que les sanctions économiques leur
retentissement il va avoir lieu avec un
peu de décalage et ce petit décalage
fait que du coup l'ukraine sera oublié
et donc la seule chose que les gens
auront c'est un problème de
portefeuilles avec peut-être un cours du
blé plus cher avec du gaz qui va flamber
avec un prix du baril de pétrole qui est
déjà très élevé donc on entend par
exemple en france beaucoup le prix à la
pompe que ce soit pour le diesel ou pour
l'essence qui a dépassé les 2 euros
voyez dans les gens s'en plaignent déjà
donc c'est là où va être le problème au
niveau en plus au-delà c'est que il ya
beaucoup d'investissements qui ont été
faits en partenariat avec la russie donc
ça ça va effectivement peser plus lourd
et puis l'autre chose qui va y avoir
c'est que en plus en ce moment en europe
on a une notion d'énergie verte qui est
mise en place et donc on prépare tout ce
qui est la décarbonisation pour être
dans le plan climat simplement la
décarbonisation aujourd'hui des énergies
alternatives elles ne fonctionnent pas
encore elles ne sont pas encore
rentables donc vous êtes sans une phase
de transition et cette phase de
transition c'est elle qui fait appel au
gaz c'est pour ça que les allemands
aujourd'hui avait choisi de se dire
verdir leurs
leur énergie en ne faisant plus de la
centrale à charbon ni nucléaire et en
disant on va passer par le gaz russe la
même chose en france voilà été abandonné
a été abandonnée donc on se retrouve
effectivement dans des difficultés qui
sont en plus des difficultés techniques
parce que par exemple quand l'allemagne
a pris cette décision elle a aussi
abandonné tout un système qui fait que
lorsque le gaz est acheminé c'est un gaz
liquéfié d'abord qui passe donc après
une fois que il revient vous devez leur
ghazi fier ça aujourd'hui c'est les
russes qui sont en charge de s'occuper
de ça et les allemands ne sont plus
aptes à le gérer nous on a la capacité
de le faire aujourd'hui total à une
usine à fos qui le fait mais avec des
tuyaux qui sont beaucoup plus petits
donc en fait c'est toute une succession
d'éléments comme ça qui va perturber les
européens l'europe de l'ouest est acquis
potentiellement va affaiblir le
portefeuille est pourquoi les européens
n'ont pas pris des sanctions ou les
américains d'ailleurs des sanctions
adnot mines m contre vladimir poutine
alors ça c'est une vraie bonne question
parce que là on est sûr de la sanction
extraordinairement ciblées et donc dans
ces cas là on peut davantage dire qu'on
ne touche pas des entreprises on ne
touche pas la population civile et donc
on fait une liste de personnes alors on
a eu dans une liste de personnes
quelques oligarques on allait patron du
fsb et c'est pourquoi parce qu'on garde
effectivement une capacité de
négociation
or on sait très bien que vladimir
poutine est très riche qui l'a déjà voir
aussi que sa famille on a d'autres etc
on pourrait effectivement aller jusque
là pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait pas ça je
ne sais pas il ya ce que c'est un manque
de courage politique est ce que c'est
une grande difficulté à savoir où sont
les avoirs de poutine jeu tout quand
même que tout le monde ignore où sont
les avoirs de vladimir poutine voit même
en partie dans les documents de
l'opposant alexeï navalni emprisonnés
est-ce que transformait vladimir poutine
en paria sur la scène internationale
comme l'a déclaré hier soir le président
américain joe biden c'est autre chose
qu'une menace verbale
alors c'est compliqué parce que en fait
la notion paria sur vladimir poutine
elle s'explique très bien du côté de
l'occident parce qu'on est très choqués
de ce qui s'est passé la façon dont les
choses se sont passées et la façon dont
il a monté en place cette opération
mais de l'autre côté du côté russe il y
à une autre logique et il y à une
logique qui a toujours été écrite a
toujours été expliquées et vladimir
poutine dans cette logique l'os se
trouve être stratège sa logique à lui
c'est effectivement qu'il faut qu'il
défende son pays qu'il faut qu'il
remonte son arme et qu' il faut
effectivement que derrière il a il a
soit une économie solide et donc il a
remonté une arme et effectivement il y
avait beaucoup d'argent et on voit que
depuis 2008 les chèques en géorgie
aujourd'hui on est passé dans quelque
chose de tout à fait différent on a la
même chose sur les sanctions économiques
la dédollarisation donc il y à une
partie de l'opinion qui ne considère pas
que vladimir poutine est aujourd'hui et
c'est un paria qui savent même lire son
discours dans des termes qui nous choque
en nous disant non ça c'est l'histoire
russe je prends un épisode par exemple
quand il a traité l'ukraine par exemple
de aujourd'hui nazis ou qu'il a parlé
d'un génocide nous évidemment c'est des
mots qui sont totalement abject et pour
ça effectivement le vladimir poutine
représente ce qu'on appelle un état
paria mais des personnes qui sont
effectivement dans une lecture de la
russie vont nous dire non non le terme
génocide aient choisi parce qu'il fait
écho au terme génocide qui a été
utilisée par les américains quand on
parlait de ce que faisait les serbes au
kosovo et qui vont re dire non mais la
notion de nazis sur l'ukraine ça
s'inscrit à la fois dans la seconde
guerre mondiale et ce qui se passait à
ce moment là puisque effectivement il ya
eu quelques figures qui ont épousé le
nazisme et d'autres qui vont rappeler
effectivement qu'il ya eu des mini ce
qui portait la signature et qu'on
appelait les ministes d'azov voyez donc
c'est ça la vue quand même des moments
de la révolution de maidan oui oui qu'on
a fait présent absolument dans l'absolu
mans donc donc ça fait c'est pour ça que
ça fait partie des réalités et c'est
pour ça que ça fait partie des
pragmatisme après je pense que la grande
erreur aujourd'hui vis-à-vis de vladimir
poutine c'est que ça fait partie
exactement comme air douanes de ses
chefs d'état auquel à un moment donné
l'occident a apporté un rêve et à un
moment donné ils se sont tournés vers
l'europe il a essayé effectivement
d'avoir beaucoup plus de contacts avec
nous est ce à ce moment là on n'a pas
peut-être pas pris à ce poids là la
russie au sérieux comme la turquie
d'ailleurs et que donc du coup au fur et
à mesure des années c'est pire que
j'allais dire la haine c'est qu'en fait
il ya de l'aigreur vous savez quand on
est accro quand on aime plus du tout
quand du coup il ya du ressenti et quand
on se bâtit différemment effectivement
on sort de la crise du coc vide on a
tous été enfermé pendant un certain
temps donc qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
a germé dans nos esprits on n'en sait
strictement rien mais indiscutablement
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui et
vis-à-vis de l'occident et vis-à-vis des
ces européens particulièrement aigre il
veut prendre une revanche oui 0